(soft piano music)
♪ He'd take the world off my shoulders ♪
♪ If it was ever hard to move ♪
♪ He'd turn the rain to a rainbow ♪
♪ When I was living in the blue ♪
♪ Why then, if he is so perfect ♪
♪ Do I still wish that it was you ♪
♪ Perfect don't mean that it's working ♪
♪ So what can I do ♪
♪ When you're out of sight ♪
♪ In my mind ♪
♪ 'Cause sometimes I look in his eyes ♪
♪ And that's where I
find a glimpse of us ♪
♪ And I try to fall for his touch ♪
♪ But I'm thinking of the way it was ♪
♪ Hoping I'll find ♪
♪ A glimpse of us ♪
(soft piano music continues)
♪ 'Cause sometimes I look in his eyes ♪
♪ And that's where I
find a glimpse of us ♪
♪ And I try to fall for his touch ♪
♪ But I'm thinking of the way it was ♪
♪ Said I'm fine and said I moved on ♪
♪ I'm only here passing time in his arms ♪
♪ Hoping I'll find ♪
♪ A glimpse of us ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)